immer mehr menschen sterben immer mehr
zivilisten immer mehr zerstörung und tod
in woche sieben des krieges lassen die
russischen gräueltaten einen vorwurf
immer lauter werden den vom völkermord
und doch fließt weiter russisches öl und
gas nach europa deutschland steckt vor
allem embargo zurück und immer mehr in
europa vor einem deutschland das vor
allem eigene interessen vertritt
die deutschen sind die haupt bremser
gegen sehr entschlossene sanktionen
ich denke früher oder später brauchen
wir auch maßnahmen gegen öl und gas
sehen sie denn nicht dass unser gas mit
blut befleckt ist
seit kriegsbeginn hat deutschland rund
neun milliarden euro für energieimporte
an russland überwiesen an die ukraine
gingen bis anfang april waffenlieferung
im wert von 80 millionen euro der grüne
wirtschaftsminister kontert die embargo
forderungen mit schreckensszenarien
wenn man jetzt sofort den schalter
umlegt wird es in deutschland zu
lieferengpässen ihrer zulieferer
abbrüchen kommen zu
massenarbeitslosigkeit zu
armut doch ökonomen haben an dieser
darstellung so ihre zweifel
die aussagen von robert habeck nämlich
dass es was ein arbeitslosigkeit gibt
massenarmut war für uns der impetus
diese studie überhaupt zu machen und das
ergebnis ist dass es sehr schwierig ist
nach exposition wirklich mit dem
neuesten stand der
wirtschaftswissenschaften source lösung
abzubilden
bachmanns berechnungen gehen lediglich
von 0,5 bis 3 prozent konjunktureinbruch
bei einem energie embargo aus auch das
deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung errechnet - drei
prozent und eine weitere studie ein
rückgang von maximal sechs prozent
ralf fücks war mal ein vordenker der
grünen jetzt hat er mit den argumenten
des grünen wirtschaftsministers so seine
probleme
es gibt schon kritische stimmen in
europa die sagen das ist germany first
was er da macht wie sehen sie ja wir
gucken schon sehr stark auf uns selbst
und vielleicht zu wenig auf die ukraine
und darauf was für europa auf dem spiel
steht doch die ampel regierung ist
bislang nicht bereit den
wirtschaftlichen preis für die
europäische geschlossenheit zu zahlen
stattdessen zweifelt der kanzler an den
erkenntnissen der ökonom es ist
unverantwortlich irgendwelche
mathematischen modellen zu rechnen
die dann nicht wirklich funktionieren
ich kenne in der wirtschaft überhaupt
niemanden der nicht genau wusste dass
das die konsequenzen wären oder scholz
ist offensichtlich unter drogen nervös
das ist ja auch verständlich
er muss entscheidungen treffen er weiß
vermute ich dass er vor der geschichte
nicht die richtige entscheidung zur zeit
trifft dann in 50 jahren wird er keine
oder holz dafür loben dass er die
deutsche chemie industrie gerettet hat
soll er wird vermutlich als der kanzler
in die geschichte eingehen der gepresst
hat und die wissenschaft legt nach das
deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung verkündet in einer
weiteren studie die energieversorgung in
deutschland sei auch ohne erdgas aus
russland gesichert denn bislang fließen
jährlich rund 50 milliarden kubikmeter
gas von russland nach deutschland die
laut diw ersetzt werden könnten über
norwegen und die niederlande wären
demnach bis ende des jahres lieferung
von bis zu 28 milliarden kubikmeter
möglich zudem ließe sich der verbrauch
in deutschland um bis zu 22 milliarden
kubikmeter senken
unter anderem durch energiesparen und
die entschädigung energieintensiver
unternehmen
nachfrage bei der regierungssprecherin
das bietet der vorwurf gemacht
deutschland sei der bremser bei den
sanktionen aufgrund der ablehnenden
haltung gegenüber einem sofortigen
embargo von öl und gas besteht die
bundesregierung dazu die bundesregierung
hat ja wie gesagt bei kohle zugestimmt
dass das ist dort ein baldiges embargo
geben wird wenn man jetzt aber nicht
geantwortet wie steht die
bundesregierung vor dem vorwurf der
bremser bei den sanktionen zu sein das
über diese themen innerhalb der eu
diskutiert wird ist ganz
selbstverständlich
doch ganz so selbstverständlich
erscheint dass einem der international
erfahrensten sicherheitsexperten nicht
wenn dies krieg so ausgeht dass von der
ukraine nur noch ein schatten übrig
bleiben
wird die suche nach den schuldigen
losgehen im ganzen westen und wird man
relativ schnell sagen als deutsche nicht
wesentlichen anteil und habe ich muss
ich ihnen wirklich sagen wo sie große
angst die ukrainischen opfer haben für
freiheit und selbstbestimmung gekämpft
für die werte europas doch den preis für
den verzicht auf russische auf billige
energie zu zahlen ist vor allem
deutschland noch immer nicht bereit
[Musik]